thank you guys for coming it's really
thrilled this is my first in-person
official talk in front of the audience
in two years
plus
so i'm super excited to
talk
the
talk about some of our
recent research so give us some some of
the overview kind of along the topics
and the autonomy that's kind of near and
dear to my heart and kind of first at
the end uh some thoughts for kind of
where the future might be what might be
open problems
so autonomous systems really especially
service robots
have
potential to help so many peoples make
their lives better and they
make their lives better completing
tasks that
elderly people people with disabilities
and so on cannot do it by themselves
right on the other hand the digital
agent this would be like your google
assistant type of thing or so on also
bring
elderly and people that don't have
access to a technology because of the
uh i don't know motion problems not
being able to interface with the devices
and so on or just not kind of technology
technologically apt be able to complete
tasks for them
uh
and kind of bring them to the
to be able to do kind of chores and so
on that are not possible right now
so
what do we need for kind of these agents
to be able to do they need to complete
the autonomous tasks in real world
the whether that means uh and that means
a long people among human
rights
environments are changing all the time
rooms are changing furniture is changing
there are sensors uncertainties and all
the nine yards around that
they also need to run on real robots and
robots come in all kinds of shapes and
sizes and their
geometry
their dynamics right their sensors and
even their compute
impacts how that motion or these tasks
actually get manifested and these things
need to come together
in addition the training becomes uh we
want generalization we want the robots
to work in
large variety of the environments so we
cannot possibly go and hard code
everything which kind of brings us to
the learning
and the generalization becomes a b
issue or the question how to do and how
do we get practical training and
deploying in this real world
so that's kind of the setup that
the problem space that we want to go by
so i'll talk about two broad topics
one is first is your zero shot transfer
the idea is and there's lots of
different perspectives in the space do
we train from the real data do we train
on real systems are we training
simulation and so on for the purpose of
this talk i'm going to talk about
training and simulation because
i don't know it's safe it's safer it's
cheaper potentially but it has the issue
that we create a sim to real gap so
let's talk about how to
ensure
zero shot transfer from training and
simulation to the real robots and then
once we can transfer the policies just
plop it on the robot
and it runs we can talk about how to get
better policies and generalization
that's going to be second part of the
talk
so three themes there
mobile navigation with the noisy sensors
safety critical visual navigation and
research constraint systems
the
for the mobile navigation
let's say in this work we want to have
robot go from a to b in unstructured
environment avoiding obstacles and so on
we assume that there is no map that it
can rely on it just needs to basically
sense what the
space is
and it's a goal condition policy so it
has a goal to go to
and just needs to get there the best
they can
kind of like i do here like if i'm gonna
go exit i'm probably gonna go this way
and go around
so reinforcement learning kind of comes
naturally to that observations here are
lidar observations and we kind of have
several of them in the goal
the actions are the linear and uh
angular velocity of the robot
and the training environment we use here
is a very simple top-down map
with static of
with static obstacles without any
dynamics and whatnot it's really like a
2d map
projection and then the objective really
that we want to do here is we completed
the task or we didn't we reached our
goal or we didn't reach the goal
however
training rl this is a semi long horizon
task that's not very scalable so becomes
question of what is the reward
and generally we have a good intuition
there about the features that can kind
of influence that reward and this is the
interesting reward they kind of give
agent
internal representation
am i progressing well towards the task
so these things would be the distance to
the goal the distance to the nearest
obstacle
the
angle right and so on we have good sense
of what might influence that decision
but not how they relate each other and
what the weights are for that function
the second
question here is how do we select neural
network architecture for this how many
layers how many how they are deep do we
do this or do we do that right
and you kind of do that with a trial and
error
so because this is a very trial and
error i'll talk more about that later
but to fear
you say okay how about we train a
population of agents we do this by trial
and error let's automate that process
so we start with a future
basically parametrization of the reward
based on these features we randomly
initialize the rewards on the population
the
nh trains with that
uh with a different kind of
parametrization of the reward once we
train the agent we evaluated on our
system how well it performs
what how many times basically it reached
the goal
and that's our task objective in this
case
and then we put that in the mutator that
then proposes
the next parametrization for the reward
and spawns the new agent and so on
it's not cheap
the but it does
produce good policy once we're done and
in this case this is about thousand
policies running
we select the reward and then we go on
the second phase where now we fix the
reward interesting reward and we're
trying to fit the neural network
architecture for that reward
so again
sure um i'm wondering
just about the reward portion of this
how does this relate to inverse
reinforcement learning where you also
can learn the reward from some
demonstration so
this would be uh one thing that we found
is
that these are these truistic rewards so
the
inverse reinforcement learning would
want to kind of get okay this is my task
characteristics right i want to be i
don't know conservative or the
preferences don't want to go slow take
more risk or not
the intrinsic reward is the reward that
helps agents learn faster
and have better behavior and what we
found is that there is a codependency
between the loss function that we're
using for training the agent
the rl loss
and the reward that it comes up
because in a way reward kind of leads
the agent in that
space and produces the training and even
reparameterizing the existing reward
can improve the the training
so
the questioner
in a way inverse reinforcement learning
learns the task objective
at least in my mind
okay so for neural network architecture
we're now fitting the neural network
architecture for the reward and again
parameterize the neural network
architecture start with a random
parametrization
and we evaluated then now and against
the cumulative reward and we repeat the
process
and now we have our policies
so the training algorithm basically we
take this very simple environment there
is the video of the environment really
super simple
it does do some basic domain
randomization in terms of adding noise
to the sensors adding noise to the
kinematic model to the action space and
so on and do the
then these two
loop
learning reward and the neural network
architecture
and that transfer zero shot transfer
plop it on the robot and it runs in in
the environments around
the
people
even on a different kinematic of the
robot the difference between fetch and
freight is about 100 pounds
and the same process works for
modrical environments which are
non-linear systems uh
even the
system is very king of the
economic constraints such as cars and
asteroid dynamics
and here is a video
in the
this is basically a start we ask robot
to go from the fixed position to that
sink and we repeated that
same trajectory over and over or same
task
and basically people were just showing
up now the path is blocked and it
basically needs to go
and adapt and go around this person is
around so needs to adapt to that to
reach their goal again no map just kind
of lidar sensors yeah this is blocked so
i'm gonna react
and go to the left and this is not
staged
the custodian showed up
so this is the real world right this is
the things that you can program ahead of
time this person kind of leaving now it
started going left and now it's kind of
found that there is a clearance opening
and so on
this works
so then the question was does it work
beyond the
robotic beyond the navigation and we
tried it on the benchmarks so mujapat
has different reinforcement learning
algorithms and this is where kind of
found out that yeah there is the
dependency between the
loss functions and the
or the rl algorithms in the reward
so we found that the more complex the
task is such as humanoid which kind of
has high degrees of freedom and so on
the more this reparametrization of the
reward helps so the orange line there is
learning the reward and
blue line is
tuning the hyper parameters using the
same method
the
next we ask whether it makes sense to do
a simple objective such as just get to
the goal in terms of this mutual task is
go as fast as you can or go as high as
you can or do we use as our task
objective the reward function is
standard in mudraco tasks which has
three parameters on the preferences
and the delta is
basically the difference between these
two
red lines which is very minuscule so
your mileage may vary whether you will
need to kind of construct more complex
reward or so on you just kind of want to
do the objective i suspect that it also
depends on the application
and then the question that we third
question that we asked there is if i we
have a fixed
training budget
do i spend that budget learning the
reward or do i spend it tuning the hyper
parameters and there's a difference
between orange and blue line here
so
if you're starting with reasonable hyper
parameters
you're more likely to get better bigger
bang for the buck
doing the reward search
so
next
i want to talk about the visual
navigation
and the idea here so with the mobile
navigation we had this very simple
simulator that we're using
now it's lighter so lighter it's a lot
easier to simulate and so on how about
if we go after
visual navigation around humans this
collaboration with claire tomlin's lab
at berkeley
the
we have two options right we train on
robot
which is good because then we're not
dealing with the
photorealism and seem to real gap from
the visual sensors however we have
people and
do we have policies that are safe to
train around people and do we have the
right representation of people
how we can get enough volunteers right
to deal with that
flip side is if we train in simulation
how do we construct the data set it's
not simple
and how do we deal with the symptom real
gap
so the idea is yeah let's go in
simulation
we construct a simulator
that is combination of two data sets
one is stanford's large
scale 3d indoor space data set
that gives us a realistic indoor spaces
that we know we can transfer to
to the robot
the second one is surreal it's a
data set of human models
that then we can go and parametrize and
we can change their height we can change
their body type they can change the
texture skin color and whatnot
the and we can attach them different
behaviors
policies that can control them
and from there now we have a simulator
that we can just parameterize with
different parameters and create
many many different environments
and humans so here are some examples
here that the simulator renders how
they are placed in the scene
the so now we can play
we can create a data set and start
training
so how do we go about training we first
set up the simulator and we practice
right
we randomly initialize the poses
we let them move it's a simulator we
create we create a solution with npc
find whichever the
associated the waypoint the where the
agent is going with respect to a human
in the scene and what is the cost that
comes with that and that's the data set
then from the data set that associate
my rgb image that robot sees and the
waypoint
we predict the cost
and then in runtime we have that model
that then planning phase saying okay
they're all my way points where should i
go
this way point that's a cost to just
select the one with the minimum cost
and that actually transfers uh zero shot
to reality without kind of totally
bypassing all the privacy
concerns associated with training with
humans
and we also see that
for example in this picture
that when we have human
and the legs are slightly moving
the model is going to go around behind
the human whereas when a human is
standing static it's going to go in
front of the human
and we're kind of figuring that maybe
it's kind of learning to associate
how the positioning of the legs with the
motion and direction where it's going
we're trying to make sense
i also see that the baseline which was
trained without humans on the scene
cuts off in front of people
whereas the one that actually had the
humans in the data set does not
and even though we didn't train it we
trained it only with a single human in
the scene
that actually can generalize
with some limitations
to having two
humans in the scene and here is a video
additional caveat here the model is
trained with the 65 degree camera and
this camera on the robot has 45 degree
field of view
so it goes here and avoids
the human
there's another
human is running coming from around the
corner
and the rubber kind of goes around it
so that's exciting to be able to have
this
it's a fairly complex problem
to be able
and last kind of in this
set that i want to share with you
is let's say quadrotors
and nano drones specifically
one thing that we don't think often
this is the crazy fly
it has whooping 33 kilobytes of the free
ram
and weighs one ounce
and cheap
so what do you do with it how do you
make it autonomous
one thing we're swooping under the scene
is that we're training this model on
gpus and whatnot and you just cannot put
the gpu on this thing right on the other
hand they can be very useful
because
hey they're cheap you can build a bunch
of them
uh you can use them for gas leak
detection for inspections
in kind of swarms and so on if you can
kind of make that system fully
autonomous
the this is collaboration with vijay
janaparei for from harvard
so sure enough
it turns out that between say intel core
i7
that we might be using for training and
raspberry pi that might be on a robot
not only they're cheaper but like the
cpu frequency is very very different
right
and the power usage in
all the nine yards and when we run two
trajectories
the purple one is trained on the is
executed on the same processor where it
was trained whereas the green one it was
trained on intel
processor but then execute it on
raspberry pi
and there is big gap between the
trajectories
which
is
the
another source of sim to real gap
something that we normally don't think
about
but it's there
and what ends up being is kind of we're
fixing bugs right
on because probably just not doing what
we're telling to do
so what we can do about that we're
building this is available in open
source
the
ear learning
which uses technical hardware in the
loop
basically we run on the desktop
our simulator
and we have
the target processor we can plug in
into the simulator and we're evaluating
the policies we evaluate the policies on
the target simulator but they're being
shown on the
uh
sorry
they're being shown at the
at the screen and so on so that way no
robots are hurt during these experiments
if they crash they crash
right
plus we can kind of get important data
about the latencies and so on and build
that in the simulator
the
so looking at the performance with the
hardware in the loop is up to 38 percent
difference in the performance so policy
that maybe had a 30 success rate it has
only 25 percent
rate on the raspberry pi and so on
the
but
we can again
taking that model putting in a simulator
we can do that
so now let's talk about source finding
how do we use this nanodrone
and
teach it or train it
to autonomously search for light
use light but you can replace the sensor
so
we built we put the light sensor on on
on the nano drone
and
the network
needs to fit on the target processor in
the ram
so the observation space cannot be huge
we cannot put the camera
so we just use the four
laser readings in four different
directions
and the action space is
uh very simple forward straight up and
down it's more of the planning and then
there's a controller underneath that's
going to go and track that trajectory
and then for the light model that's
going to simulate that we collect the
data observe how the light changes based
on the distance and what not build that
in a simulator and train it with
reinforcement learning
and then
use the okay let's see
so this is again
that policy trend goes directly on the
robot it go towards the light source
and so on
so this is just kind of to think of
whether from the machine learning
perspective
i want to know
if i have a model what processor do i
need to have
or how large it needs to be or if i know
what my processor is how big the network
should be
and
i think it's important source of sim to
real gap that we
don't talk much
so that runs up this line talk about
three sources of symptom real gap and
potentially how to address them
using a for mobile navigation very
simplified simulator and reward learning
with neural network architecture
on the
visual robot navigation
combining two data sets
of the buildings and humans
and creating a data set that we can kind
of train and
avoid the privacy and safety issues
associated with training in reality
and we use the self-supervision we
generalize as the previous experience
then as a model to aid the planning at
the runtime
the
to
to train the model and
enable it to run on the system
and finally we talked about the modeling
the target processor and system design
for these compact models and resource
constraint
any questions here yeah
i'm not sure if i missed it but did you
uh did it did i ever come up uh like do
you run into any problems with like
visibility changing between the
simulation and when you run it in real
life or is that not a problem
can you repeat the question what's
changing between the uh so feasibility
like in the context of like the the
middle section like safety critical
visual navigation you mentioned that you
train using npc in the simulation and
then you try to implement it in the real
world i'm just wondering like did you
observe any changes in feasibility
between those two domains or no
uh the feasibility changes because of
the camera differences field of view the
mpc
basically we have a number of
the mpcs just use the computer cost
as a prediction right and then on on the
on the robot once we have the trajectory
we have a controller that kind of goes
and execute it towards the policy
as a separate
so these two are kept the same at least
in this
case
but
when the robot can go reachable did you
find uh that the policy sometimes
reaches a local minimum the robot is
stuck or do you know if the robot was
able to is it actually actively
exploring the map and building an
internal representation or
is it locally trying to reach the goal
good question it's
reactive policy so it doesn't have a map
and basically you can kind of think of
it that
i need to be
after this
300 meters in this direction down
in campus i don't know the map but
that's kind of my
so what am i going to do all right i'm
going to start going this way
and i'm going to try to kind of keep the
direction and there's a giant wall in
front of me i'm probably going to get
stuck
and
the training we found during the
training
that
more training
helps
specifically when we're giving the
distances to the goal when we're
training how far are my goals
that that's there is like a distribution
so it's going to be able to go further
but not too much so if you were training
into 10 meters it's going to be able
maybe to go to 15 20 but not further
and then in the later that's not
published we went and did the log
of the distances
so
at that point it really had no
no constraint even if it was really kind
of
entrenched in kind of like there was
the goal was not reachable because it
was in inside the box or something like
that you were gonna keep trying to go
towards it and indefinitely but
he was able to kind of go up to 200
250 meters to find
the goal through kind of their corridors
and whatnot
the architecture
no in the in this case there is no lstm
architecture
we do we do feed three last observations
of the sensors which kind of gives it
noisy estimates of
speed
sure any other questions
before for the first part
i saw that you trained the policy and
then you tried it on different robots
so does the policy learn the profile of
the sensor what if for different robots
some of the lighters are noisier or some
of the lighters have a shorter range
what does that look like so
going
differential drive to differential drive
we didn't do additional training
the reason this sort of kind of worked
is we actually had a fun demo where
we're kind of having people sit on faith
and drive around
we should start adding this
in the talk the reason why that
intuitively works is because we're doing
basically planning at 10 hertz
so if it's not quite there where we
thought it was going to be it kind of
starts all over again
for the other types of robots are car in
the asteroid and so on we retrain the
model for we're basically using the same
methodology
does it answer your question yeah
all right
so on the second part let's talk about
how to make to learn
better stuff and more complicated things
so better generalization and harder
problems
the i already started like with with the
reward search in neural network
architecture when training reinforcement
learning agents
we have lots of decisions to make
the there are questions around how to
select reward neural network
architecture which algorithm to choose
what environment to train on and
the reality is as an engineer or
researcher
the you keep interacting with the system
observing what it does you make a new
decision
and so on that's the iterative process
reality is it's interaction between you
as an engineer and the system that
you're training and you're observing
you're collecting the data and you're
making your decision in the sequential
decision making process
right
and we can kind of see this
reinforcement learning system is a
complex system
in a sense that there are
co-dependencies between its inner parts
what the reward is and the loss function
right and the reward that we still kind
of just barely understand
so if this is interaction between
a decision maker
yourself
and a system
well then it should be learned
and you can remove yourself from the
loop
so we talked about two different ways to
do this for the rewarded neural network
architecture but next thing i want to
talk about the
learning loss functions
and
choosing the environments and learning
curriculum
so the learning loss functions
this was work that was at
iclear this year
the idea is there's lots of research
over the last couple of years on
reinforcement learning algorithms and
seems like is a new algorithm coming
every i don't know two weeks
or not people are tweaking this people
are picking that which kind of raises
fundamental questions is the way we're
developing these algorithms sound
are the benchmarks we're using sound
because if they're not sound then why
we're kind of keep changing this when
you have domain specific or whatnot but
let's kind of that's kind of more of the
longer term question
anyway the
since there's lots of tweaks and
improvements can we automate the process
and can we learn new algorithm
and the insight is that the loss
function here is really a computational
graph this is a dq and loss function
where it kind of adds certain terms and
so on
so if this is a computational graph
can we use evolutionary methods to
replace pieces reconnect the graphs and
maybe come up with something better
and that's what we kind of set out to do
so almost similar idea like we did with
the rewards right but now in the
search space here is graphs
the
we have our set of training environments
that use three
first one is hurdle environment which is
the inverted pendulum and the idea is
it's very easy to fail and it's fast to
fail and if you can train on the
inverted pendulum you have no business
don't go going further
and then if you graduate then you get
two very simple maze problems to train
on
and then once the algorithm is or the
loss function is evaluated it's
evaluated against
well using the same the performance on
these two environments
we send that to the mutator that
maintains the population
there is a trick here that because the
search space is large we also hash these
functions
loss functions so if we see that
the function with the same hash already
appeared we're now going to retrain it
again but we're going to just use that
performance
as well yeah
i'm wondering how are the viral
algorithms that you take parameterize
like what are the things you're mutating
about so we're mutating the graph
okay the
yeah so here here was the graph and say
okay the graph the
operations are
additions
multiplication
summations query yeah and then
connections
and when we're proposing when the
mutator proposes the new graph beyond
the hashing it also looks that it's well
posed
which means that
the input or state in action and reward
and output is a scalar so anything
that's not a scalar is pruned and if it
doesn't produce scaling scalar it just
lost away so that what comes out of the
mutator is actually where form graph
that stands a chance
and then we can start from scratch
in training in which case we actually
rediscovered the td algorithm
the or we can
bootstrap it with in this case with dqn
and we'll kind of see we test it on the
test environment that are not seen
so bootstrapped through the dqn we get
with this algorithm
which we call dq and regularized or dq
and reg
the
what was interesting it's really a
version of the entropy regularization
it has a term that early on in training
it kind of tampers down the queue
function it's very similar to like a cql
or one one of these new ones
that are
kind of coming out more recently
the
it does regularize uh generalized to
unseen mini grids
the purple line is the new algorithm and
then the westerner like ddqn
and cql and so on and there is a video
it almost seems like it aids with the
exploration which is kind of weird
that's not what was optimized for or so
on
the second one is
it generalized atari games we try this
four the numbers on the left are
reported from their respective papers
and it beats all four of them
which is very interesting never seen
visual observations right and so on
now cool thing about it
this is
a
graph output is a math formula
so
it's completely interpretable and we can
use the same methods that we now analyze
human-created algorithms they can serve
these learned algorithms can serve as an
inspiration for human design
right or can be served and so on
so it's consistently delivered up to the
constant so change the seeds this guy
keeps coming up
with this search space
we open sourced and made available
database of top thousand performing
algorithms if anybody is interested in
kind of doing a theoretical analysis on
them and so on is there
what's interesting is this is really
first time that we have
tens of thousands or twenty thousand
tens of thousands reinforcement learning
algorithms
at the disposal
and
we haven't like
as a community we didn't have that
before
so what's interesting when i kind of
plot the histogram of the performance
is that even though we have so many
algorithms we maybe only have
or the order of 100
different performances
which makes me wonder i don't have an
answer for this i'd love to hear an
answer is is there some kind of strange
equivalence class
that we're not aware of that many of
these loss functions and so on
map to the same performance
again database is there i'd love to kind
of hear an answer on that
d and so on and we're experimenting now
with the continuous action algorithms in
this space but anyway
so the second part and we have okay
good with time talk about generative
curriculum for compositional tasks this
is kind of a question what
if we want to do a really complex tasks
tasks that are kind of growing in
complex complexity and having emerging
complexity instead of what kind of
robotics is doing now maybe we're
learning fixed number of tasks and so on
the question is what environments do we
feed them and how we train them
so for this i want to kind of take a
step
aside from robotics for a moment and
talk about the autonomous web navigation
and we first say okay while we're
talking about web navigation i'm going
to argue that this is a mobile
navigation task
so consider a task where you're trying
to
purchase a flight or purchase something
on amazon or or order a food
you have a set of pages
each page
even on the same website changes
right sometimes you have different ad
sometimes you have this or that
the
you
enter information you change
the state of that's your manipulation
aspect right after several manipulation
aspects you hit that submit button you
move to the next room
right
it's a mobile manipulation there are
things that you can mess up there the
you can order thousand of something not
a good thing
right the
there are things that
that ends going contact customer service
that's completely not relevant to your
task and kind of gets gets you derailed
and so on
action space is huge you need to know
what information to input where action
space changes from page to page from
element to element what is it you put
there and then primitives what are in
this case things like okay enter first
name or better dates
enter date okay is this a drop down is
it a text
is it
is it a little pop
pop out right so there are many many
different manifestations how that can do
and in this case we actually work from
the html side and the dom side so the
variation of how even the date or first
name
or something can manifest the semantic
primitive how it can manifest
their countable ways
to do that so it's very complex
space to work with and one thing that we
do as people is
we do this zero shot okay maybe you kind
of go to a new website to do something
and you kind of do it right you you
figure it out without kind of additional
training and so on so can we have a
single agent that solves any task in
these class of related tasks
the
so where is kind of the current state of
the art in in the web navigation space
commercial websites so like southwest
and so on have
dom trees with 30 000 elements
on on the on the web page
the benchmark
that
existed has hundred
and there is a huge gap that's kind of
what's needed for the real world and
kind of where the benchmarks are
and then the previous state of the art
in a sense was learning
for a single
domain so
single website and what not using
millions of examples
and they're just not going to fly in
in reality
so we want to do autonomous navigation
in these unreal
real environments
which means again we need to train in
simulation
and the classic methods and whatnot
they're just not going to work we need
to go towards some sort of curriculum
right
and maybe we have this interaction of
a model basically the idea is to have
interaction between a model
that observes how
students or the
agents under training are performing
and then it proposes the environment
that is the right level
for their skill level and kind of goes
back and forth
so but first we now need to know what
we're learning
so we formalize this uh task space as
petrinas
and
if you're not familiar with patronage
they're graphs
and there are two types of nodes there
are circles which are states
and there are rectangles which are
triggers which an external agent
basically
triggers an action and then there is
like this little circle that says okay
now we're kind of doing a state
transition between them
and this really nicely describes we make
a connection between petri net
and
bomb mdps
what are the observations right and so
on by using petronas we can formalize
what the task space is
so for the web navigation in particular
we can say that
our primitives are first names and so on
and there is associated for that
semantic we have a number or the set of
primitives that kind of match
the
and then the pages we have a gate which
is basically a bottleneck state and then
the next state and so on so there is a
structure to that task
and since there is one-to-one mapping
between
the petrinet and palm mdp our problem
becomes then that we want to learn a
single policy
that
maximize expecting return or that family
of palm mdps that are defined or induced
by the set of
the petrinets
so now that we have structure of the
task
we can create
a simulator
that builds these
websites because the petrinas tells us
where the connections are and then
primitives can be sampled out of the
database as as they are needed
so this is precisely what we do for
example here this is just kind of
illustrative for
the uh southwest website that there are
different uh kind of
paths to to generate the branches and
whatnot
so the first step for the simulator is
that we create a set of primitive
objects this would be our little dom
elements that you can scrape from web
and whatnot
and the
now that we have
the to create the website out of that
set of primitives we can decide how many
pages we have and sample out of it and
connect them
the
and then on top of that
the simulator just kind of allows us to
do that the question now is okay which
ones should we create how do we create
and so on and this is where it kind of
gets into the methods
so we call this compositional design of
the environments
or the code and it is a multi-agent
system right
the we have a designer lstm
that first selects how many pages are
going to be on the website
and then goes in and basically the codes
and selects the primitives and connects
them into websites
that created website which by the way
it's not semantically correct because
there is nothing to forces semantics we
can give have 35
dates
there
and so on
is being presented
to
the age population of agents and the
training
they are trained on that environment for
a number of step
and then the designer observes
the regret which is estimated as
the range of
how well this population of agents did
so did they all do well or did they not
do well
and so on or there's like a if there is
a variety that's a good thing
and then the second one is what's the
best agent's performance
so these are the two signals
and from there
the designer has this two-part laws
that
first part of the losses this size is
the budget
so if the agent the best performing
agent is not doing well
it's basically encouraged to drop
the difficulty and kind of make things
easier
and if the best performing agent is
doing well it's encouraged to increase
the difficulty and make things more
challenging and complete more
complicated tasks
and the second part of the last function
is
the regret which kind of looks at the
range
of the how well the agents are
performing
and if they're though all performing
differently it's encouraged to pick
different primitives to make things more
interesting and challenging and so on so
it's not kind of all uniform
so basically we have two
models being co-trained at the same time
really not knowing about each other
the
and then for the evaluation we manually
created websites that
are not
any of these
generated and we evaluate them and these
are semantically correct
so what are the results
the first we notice that early on in
training they're very simple
couple of fields and so on later on they
become more complex which is kind of
cool that's kind of what we expected
second the blue line is the performance
of our model
the
red and green lines are
domain randomization
manual curriculum
and paired with just has one of the laws
doesn't have the budgeting loss
and so on
so clearly this one keeps
going
the end we kind of see generalization
the across
the time
and then the third thing we notice that
the distribution of the primitives that
are being selected
shifts during the training
early on it kind of basically more or
less uniformly uh selects the primitives
where the later on kind of starts
selecting the elements that are more
relevant to the task so there would be
less of images added
and more of okay give me the date field
and stuff that the agents need to
practice
the
and then the question was okay this so
this is a synthetic benchmark
that we
created 40 primitives and so on does
they hold water in reality
so for that
we went and scraped
3 500
this kind of dom elements primitives of
the real websites
indeed this induces the learnable space
of 10 to the power 31
so it's kind of huge
the
and the difference between this is that
now the primitives out of distribution
from those that we have in our simulator
the this is like human coded or machine
coded right and so on
so this particular set
of the primitives that we used was kind
of heavily focused over its password
changing
the it has a lot of login and password
in terms of the primitive
and
not many of the other
so in terms of the results
the this is on the benchmark the login
is the highest performing with about 60
plus
success rate whereas the others that
does not have the proper distribution of
the primitives are much lower about 20s
but then we went and evaluated that
model on the in distribution the held
out set that came out of
the the real website so at this point
now they're in distribution primitive
and we're getting accuracy about 93
the
which kind of
i'm super excited about this because it
means that the benchmark
is actually
refl accurately reflecting the
difficulty of the tasks we want to learn
and the so the the benchmark is open
source now and
and it's available
so we have
we're good and good with that
so on better generalization we talked
about learning reinforcement learning
algorithms and exciting part thing about
that is that these are interpretable
loss functions
that we can use in co-design
with humans or use our tool set that we
know and love
to to learn more about reinforcement
learning algorithms
uh
also on this line we saw that evolution
changes the energy agent itself
whereas on the web navigation
part we have a very large task space
and we're learning a generative model
that
learns the curriculum and just changes
the training data for the agent and the
training
so it's a very different paradigm for
the
learned curriculum
curriculum learning only observes how
the agents under training are performing
they can be we are using rl here can be
imitation learning hackie can be humans
right
as long as we just can observe how well
they're doing
that's all good and fine
the
and then on the other hand from the
perspective of the reinforcement
learning agent that we're training here
it doesn't know anything about the
curriculum
right
and the only thing it knows is okay this
is the environment i should train on
this is the exercise i should do and so
on and where it's coming from and so on
it has no idea
and the only difference is between this
work and the one that i said oh it takes
million samples
to learn on a single environment
neural network architecture reward all
the same
the only thing that we change is what is
being fed to this agent
and that's kind of mind-boggling right
that
so
i think there's more to be said about
that
so you can see that these kind of things
can be learned
but what are the next steps then
i'm really curious about this what is
the fundamental role of nurture versus
nature in rl
going back in the difference between
evolutionary algorithms change the
neural network architectural laws and
whatnot the systems perspective of the
agents
and
the web navigation part and the learn
curriculum just changes what the agent
is seeing
right the data
what is the interplay how do we combine
the two should we combine them do we do
i don't know i would love to see i don't
have answers i'd like to see kind of
more
going down that direction
second question is
should we do there has been like endless
debate around do we do simulation in the
loop or data only
and so on there's been so many debates
and questions and so on
with a recent raise of large language
models
which are kind of showing that with lots
of data maybe we don't need a simulator
on the other hand in robotics
can we ever have that much data i don't
know
and one thing that kind of supervised
models are doing well
are they doing well when the data is
clean
robotics
by nature
the robotics is not clean the sensors
are noisy and so on so i think the
supervised community can learn
something from robotics in terms of how
to deal with the noisy
stuff
the question is whether robotics can
kind of go and
abandon simulators and what not or what
should be a happy compromise but i would
expect that actually might have some
consensus on that debate in the next
couple years
we'll see
third part that i'm kind of interested
is
i'm going to talk a bit about the
constraint systems
is
can we have
can we get to the point that we have
application targeted system where we can
co-design
with the application target application
in mind then we can design both software
and the hardware architecture some of
our preliminary work so we can perform
we can get maybe
two to three times performance gains if
we co-design accelerators with the
neural network architectures
and so on but being able to
say this is my specs for the task and
the environments that i want whatever
they are
and you kind of click a button and you
have your system designed and your chip
shipped that would be really exciting
and then last but not least
one of the major hurdles
that prevents adoption of autonomous
systems and robotics and so on is user
trust
well 50 percent i think it's 53 percent
of users
do not want autonomous
data that whether it's robots or driving
cars
surgeons and whatnot
in their lives because they don't trust
the system
so what are the methods that we can
build that user trust
interact with the user
verification methods large benchmarks
and so on to actually
solve that because if we don't have user
trust we're just doing academic research
we're not going to change anybody's
lives
and the studies i kind of just my
thoughts
and with that
i want to thank my collaborators and
thank you
i think we have a few more questions for
thank you so much uh alexandra so are
there any questions in the audience also
uh people on zoom feel also free to
unmute yourself and ask the questions so
there's the first one there
the environment uh the mobile
installation uh it reminded me a lot of
uh generative serial networks and so i
was wondering if you ran into
training stability issues there as well
where it would get stuck in open minima
or maybe would
optimize so that all of the environments
were very simple but very hard and
wonderful so the first shot will be to
be for
the so we started with paired method
that came out of
the
last year or so that only used the
regret loss
and there was talking in the minima it
wasn't learning and so on and that
actually prompted us towards a
expanding with the budget tecano allows
us to do these long horizon
tasks
the because then we can kind of control
the difficulty
and second
it really prompted us
towards thinking about the structure of
the task
what turned out is that the task that
appeared was originally
uh developed for
was not was for the open-ended tasks
and the feasibility of the task was not
was basically what paired was originally
differentiating for to create the
feasible tasks and so on
in this case
we saw that if we say this
there is a structure in this task
and we can kind of define them grammar
question than is how do you define
different tests but beyond that that
they are feasible
your providing environment is solvable
and that kind of helped going out of the
local minima and stopping
the
yeah
i think this
more question
when you're testing a new environment
did you have a way to quantify the
difference between the training
environments and the testing environment
and did you observe
like performance degradation then
the environment is now too different
than what he's trained for that's a good
question
there was another line of work that i
didn't talk about that was looking at
the metric between the new and this was
kind of more the fine tuning
the but not in this case it's actually
very good question if i know observe the
the similarities
finally the similarity metric is not a
most real thing though
any more questions also anyone on zoom
uh happy to hear your questions if you
want to unmute yourself
where the i would guess the nature part
of it or like what we know so far from
the structure robotics methods can come
in and
kind of tease out what the just learning
from scratch could not
do right now at this point how do you
think this would proceed
that's a very good question
the
one thing is for sure
roboticists need to be much more careful
and selective around the data
because we don't have
as much data
the and i
the big question whether we'll ever have
second part is that the data we have is
not perfect coming up with
good data is difficult and it's more
difficult for robotics
the because i think there are some
uncertainty there that are just
interesting to the system and we cannot
get
past that
so i i think the opportunity is really
for robotics then since we're kind of
working in this space of
what what can we do best with the
cheapest data that we can get by
to then use these methods and and apply
them to
to non-robotics domains
okay well in that case thank you again
thank you for coming
[Applause]